can't figure out what to give the friend
who's got it all just in time for the
holidays 2 Chainz is here to help these
are the seven craziest gifts from his GQ
series most expensive as [ __ ] if you can
afford them that is number seven thirty
thousand dollar headphones to make that
private jet flight just a bit more
comfortable when they were originally
put out by sennheiser the list price was
i think about 12,800 just under 13 on
ebay they stabilized around 20 or 21
thousand until the Japanese collectors
came in the market and now they're back
over to bounce your little tingly
feeling on inside that's me it is I
sound good at number six for the
sharpest dresser you know try a suit
that costs more than your car our suits
go between 7500 otters and ninety-five
hundred dollars we also have things that
are much rarer than that things like
vykk unit what's the difference if I
kuna and let's say cashmere goat it's
just ray so if I kunis suit would be
fifty thousand dollars so if I kuna top
coat is about sixty thousand dollars I
want to feel some Bach Kona can't blame
me I could sleep with there you go yeah
that is nice and so I'm probably gonna
roll a pajama suit made in that a
thousand dollar ice cream sundae hope
you're hungry dude you don't even have
the cooking ice cream and it still cost
a [ __ ] arm and a leg how much is this
Sunday for the record holding champion
like yourself Joe what is this Sunday
Tim with the cost of a right I'm sure
probably eat them every week one
thousand dollars
but let's not forget dental hygiene
follow up the sunday by brushing with a
five-thousand-dollar toothbrush how much
is this expensive to bursley I can I
would like to take a guess this one is
titanium he has a special pay I say this
to persons with $99 this toothbrush is
3,200 euros which is over four thousand
dollars at number three give the
cigar-chomping kingpin in your life this
a bespoke Panama hat what's your most
expensive hat thank you so 25 bucks
25,000 this is man worked on it for one
year Wow $25,000 but one hat want to
upgrade your home theater how about 250
thousand dollar speakers all the better
to bump two chains of course it is
something like this cost like what does
it run more than you'd imagine as you're
seeing it it's 260 thousand dollars it's
260 yeah bands like we would say bang
260 fans and the most expensive estuve
are expensive ship rare cars plural to
park in front of your mansion you do
have a mansion right 345 thousand
dollars this is over heaven 35,000 the
dirt on this car alone with 20 pounds
yeah enemy to minnesota's karma glad to
be close to your rich days even if
you're all set on stocking stuffers be
sure to share this list with a friend
and while you're at it head over video
GQ calm and GQ's youtube channel for the
first season of 2 chainz's most
expensive as [ __ ]
you